you know i read something about your
life that
is like mind-blowing to me okay like
like but tell me if it's true even i
don't know because a lot of this stuff
is you know [ __ ] when you were like
15 16 did you hang out with the stones
you know what it was i was doing uh it
was the first
thing i had ever really done and i went
and did this tommy hilfiger shoot yeah
and how does that happen i met
uh i don't remember i really don't
remember are you modeling uh
really i was i was acting i i did like
one little thing on party of five right
and that was your first acting job party
of five yeah you went your audition i
auditioned and i got the part and i was
16 my parents wouldn't ever let me leave
school for very long so i couldn't do
anything that was too crazy
that took too long uh but i i ended up
doing this tommy hilfiger shoot with a
bunch of kids and jesse wood was one of
them who was ronnie woodson right and
then i ended up in
the studio and i remember keith richards
was like i i couldn't understand a
single thing he was saying
but he took me around and by the end of
going around this he took me around he
showed me his guitars and all the things
that were you know
in the studio and by the end of it i
could like translate for people you know
what i mean like i don't know how that
happened but i almost said you
completely understood everything that
you became a keith richards whisperer
but honestly you certainly must realize
that's a very unusual thing for a kid
who was like 15 or 16 to be hanging out
with the stones yeah i would think
there's like sort of an effort that you
have to be cool around them was there
some sort of pressure and all that i
think you just want to like not get
kicked out so you just sort of like i i
don't know if it's cool as much as it's
just
kind i don't know you know i i i i
excited i mean that was really an
extraordinary cool moment were you a big
big fan yeah i'm a big music fan you
know and i love i love music i do i play
the piano yeah i feel like you want to
be a musician i i am a musician i feel
like a musician but i just don't do it
for a living are you writing songs yeah
oh yeah i write songs all the time why
don't you pull a jared leto get a band
together do that go on the road i get
nervous
what singing are you like one of those
people that can't perform live i'm
getting better i'm that's been sort of
my thing is like
i i want i want to like just be like
[ __ ] it yeah you're saying nothing
compares to you at a charity event you
were really good yeah we actually played
that now that i'm thinking about it oh
yeah you did that's kind of easy you
know what that was actually really i i
it's the whole thing is on youtube which
is a little
weird how that ended right
uh i was
i never sing and and my it was my mom's
charity event right and david foster was
there and we literally he's like we
gotta we gotta go do something and i'm
like david i can't i don't even know
what to sing
and he's like well you know what i
thought of nothing compares to you
because did you have it memorized you
knew nothing compares to you no i had it
on my um iphone oh yeah so we just
literally like
that's not a rehearsed thing and so i
was just so happy that we got through it
yeah
yeah um
and then for that unrehearsed thing to
be like where people were like you're
you singing you did a really good job
maybe that's why you were good because
you just did an impromptu like you
weren't all nervous i'm better rehearsed
we hear you sing nothing compares to you
what listen
[Music]
i was shocked
[Music]
[Music]
you like this i love music and i have
such appreciation for really good
songwriters yeah me too um i'm the same
way you know and and then there's
certain voices that just they do little
things that make you crazy you know
where you go oh that's such a god
given gift
you